bonjour c'est malik bentalha pour brut
ma prof d'espagnol a changé ma vie au
lycée parce que c'est la première rame
avoir conseillé de me lancer dans le
théâtre et elle a convoqué mes parents
pour leur expliquer qu'il fallait que je
monte à paris tenté ma chance et les
parents d'accepter bizarrement et par la
suite
je suis rentrée dans une école de
théâtre qui s'appelle le cours florent
j'y suis resté quatorze mille euros la
salle de classe pour moi c'était
vraiment le laboratoire parfait pour
essayer des vannes et il faut avoir le
sens du timing c'est à dire qu'il faut
faire la bonne vanne quand le prof ne
parle pas trouvé la manière de faire la
vanne sans que le prof nous nous en
veuille
il faut que ce soit drôle est que le
prof se disent je peux pas le jeu peut
pas le punir parce que c'est marrant
donc c'était vraiment une bonne salle
d'entraînement et puis elle elle était
très clientes de ça et un jour elle m'a
dit cette phrase qui m'a vraiment qu'il
ya vraiment eu de l'écho chez moi elle
m'a dit m'a dit t'es vraiment une belle
merde au livre d'or elle m'a dit elle
m'a dit cette phrase elle m'a dit
qu'elle voulait faire du flamenco quand
elle était plus jeune et que ses parents
ne l'avaient pas laissé et
qu'aujourd'hui elle regretté d'être
d'être prof et qu'elle aurait aimé faire
du flamenco presque et ça s a eu
vraiment beaucoup d'échos chez moi et
elle me dit faut pas que tu vis avec des
regrets et cette phrase vraiment résonne
encore aujourd'hui donc donc vraiment
merci à madame du puits au moment de mon
arrivée à paris j'ai 18 ans et ça change
tout pour moi dans l'histoire qui va
suivre parce que 18 ans j'ai quitté ma
province 1
bien décidé à empoigner la vie mais ça y
est je suis dans une grande ville je vis
seul et je suis en train de faire ce que
j'aime je fais du théâtre et surtout je
commence à écumer les scènes ouvertes
parisienne et je les fais tout c'est à
dire pendant en 2007-2008 et là je
prends mon petit baluchon et je fais le
tour des des cafés théâtres parisiens ça
va du café de paris le chinchman comedy
club savent à part ça passe par le
pranzo il y avait aussi une scène
ouverte de 2,7 milliards rue de la
roquette aussi où vit toujours bien
reçus j'ai été un des premiers à aller
au paname aussi et j'ai toujours été
bien reçue dans tous ces endroits avec
bienveillance et j'étais le plus heureux
du monde parce que c'était une manière
de pouvoir tester ses vannes de
rencontrer d'autres d'autres humoristes
en devenir
c'est là que j'ai rencontré aussi mais
mes premiers potes dans l'humour
j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent en
chapeau c'est à dire qu'on se partager
l'argent qu'ils avaient dans le chapeau
et parfois on repartait chacun avec 4 5
6 euros 7 euros
et c'était déjà incroyable parce qu'avec
ses 7 euros c'étaient les 7 euros de
notre de notre travail donc on était on
était ravi on était comme des fous est
vraiment le début parisien les débuts
parisiens c'est peut-être mes plus beaux
souvenirs c'était galère mais c'est en
même temps mes plus beaux souvenirs
c'était galère parce que parce qu'il
fallait vivre à paris et c'était une
notion que j'avais pas forcément en tête
que la vie était différente à paris et
la vie était beaucoup plus cher donc
quand je suis arrivé j'ai eu plein de
petits boulots j'ai bossé au starbucks
jégo sur mac do j'ai fait nous nous j'ai
distribué des flyers devant le point
virgule
j'ai fait plein de petits boulots pour
essayer de ne pouvoir me payer 1,1 mètre
carré
un moment vraiment qui a été très
important dans ma dans ma petite
carrière c'est mon premier succès au
cinéma c'est pattaya un film de franck
gastambide est un film qui a connu un
succès qui a fait deux millions
d'entrées alors qu'on en espérait même
pas la moitié
ça a été assez incroyable et ça a changé
beaucoup de choses dans le sens où on
m'a proposé d'autres choses par la suite
et j'ai connu une espèce de deux moments
assez incroyable le soir de la première
le soir de la sortie de pattaya où on
termine devant et revenantes de leonardo
dicaprio et et c'est assez fou d'être de
se retrouver trois gars en thaïlande est
d'être devant devant y revenant à la
soirée chiffres donc ça a été un moment
magnifique est vraiment un moment comme
on en vit aura peu je pense